about a year and a half ago shane you
wrote a book entitled what you don't
learn in film school
so if we proposed a sequel to this book
maybe what they don't teach you after 20
years in the film industry
what would be the main crux of that book
that's a great question
um
wow
i think you know as i talk about in the
book
every day i learn something new
every day and i've been producing for
over 30 years and i you know been in
this industry
49 of them
and every day i learned something new
and i i think
what's most important is is whether
you're on the executive side or you're
on the artistic side i think you have to
be open to change
you have to be open to
learning from your mistakes and owning
them i think i don't think enough people
own their mistakes and i think we grow
from our mistakes instead of burying
them and having a fall guy or a
scapegoat i think the biggest thing that
i see is people not learning
um i think i think it goes back to
putting your pride aside you know i've
come from a very humble
educational documentary film beginning
and then was very fortunate to to run a
company that did a lot of studio films
and you know ultimately doing gridiron
gang and working with networks and i
have
i have
come back to being an indie guy and and
it's by choice i mean i don't know maybe
nobody wants me in hollywood proper but
i didn't give them the chance to say
they didn't i just decided to go back to
what i love
but what i see in a lot of the people
that i that i come in contact with or i
i work with that are trying to find
their way
is
i think they're more concerned about
public perception about what they do and
how they come off than actually doing
the work
i find more people spend
most of their time trying to gloat about
what they're doing on social media and
hey i get it it drives drives projects
for some people a lot of people are more
interested in
having you know fake it to you make it
or perception is everything i i get that
i don't i don't endorse it but i
understand it and i think
what what i find interesting is there's
some of these filmmakers that i that i
personally know
will
absorb a lot of information whether it's
from me or other people that you've had
on film courage or other filmmakers that
they know that have been through the
good the bad and the ugly
and they love taking the meetings but
they don't apply it
and i'm just as guilty of it i'm not
saying that
you know i have all the answers because
i clearly don't
but i one thing i don't do is i'm you
know i learned to sing when i was in
high school is it even a dumb dog
doesn't look a hot stove twice
i try not to do that in what i do i try
to learn and make the next better
you know even if it's just from a
production standpoint last time we were
together i was getting ready to do a
film in the heat of covid you know we
shot that in november december october
november and december of last year in
when other projects were getting shut
down
um we we took over 400 coveted tests we
didn't have one positive
we we had so much fun we had i always
worked with a small crew anyway they
gave us you know with the mandates from
the union we we couldn't have more than
20 people on a set including cast and
crew
it was the most fun i ever had making a
movie in my life
and moving forward
i've learned
to take that experience and how i can
make the next project better for for
everybody and it wasn't just about
having a smaller crew or being stuck
doing three tests a week for covid it
was it was about
i think there was a lot of it was people
were so happy to be back out working and
interacting with each other
but it reminded me again of the respect
that we need to have for one another
how blessed we are to be in this
industry whether you're making a 500
film or a 50 million dollar film we are
equally as blessed where we get to do
something we love
and just
trying to remind ourselves it's only a
movie
i learned something from martin sheen
100 years ago we were doing a film
together and it shot over over the
holidays and god god bless him he
he for some reason he didn't go back for
one of the holidays when everybody else
broke so it was it was adam kane
martin sheen myself and and i think it
was susan mcguire our a.d and the four
of us went out to a holiday dinner
in arizona we were making a film
and he told the story of his heart
attack on apocalypse now you know which
everybody's heard different versions of
it i heard it directly from him and i'm
not going to relay the story i wouldn't
want to waste everybody's time on that
you can research it
but the one thing mr sheen said is he
was being wheeled into the hospital for
his surgery after having his heart
attack
was his wife jan leaned over and looked
at him and said it's only a [ __ ]
movie martin
and here at that time they didn't know
it was going to be one of the most
iconic films in hollywood history
but when when he said that i never
forgot it because what we do is special
to us and hopefully the people that our
work touches and people that see it but
in the grand scheme of life
it's only a movie
and i try to remember that i try to
remember that
when we go on set every day
you know we're blessed to be there have
a smile you're not sitting in a cubicle
trying to raise money to make a movie
you're out making a movie
um
and i i
and again it's it's just
i think the next book going back to your
question of an hour and a half ago karen
i think is
it's bringing a sense of of joy and and
feeling
blessed regardless of what it is you're
doing we all want to do bigger better
things at a bigger scale and get paid
more for it but it's not about that be
in the moment love the moment and
realize that
you know people only go go to the moon
once usually i don't think there's many
people have been to the moon twice and
and i look at every opportunity to shoot
a film is going to the moon
and
just enjoy the moment build those
relationships um treat people that you
the way you want to be treated because
the day's going to come or that pa on
your set is going to be the guy running
hbo or
you know
three arts entertainment or something
and and you know it's it's mind-blowing
how
going back to what we talked about with
suits and artists it's the way people
treat each other especially in this
business it's not always favorable and
i know i'm not perfect and i've i've
raised my voice and been upset with
people and i i'd like to think i go back
and make it right
but i think what i'd like to see people
do is is build more relationships
and build more of a family within their
core
not just look to get through tuesday get
the film done on time on budget move on
i
think you look at some of the most
successful filmmakers that that have
come through and especially in the old
days and there was a there was a family
you know when hitchcock made his films
people all stepped up and helped each
other there wasn't a divide you know
when he was making psycho and he was
sick and was out for a week or two you
know the ad directed the film his wife
stepped in and did some directing
i mean you know that's that's a family
atmosphere and i i wish there would be
more of that in our industry and people
weren't just interested in me me me i
think it's it's about us
stronger together
you think too
so if we if we took the first book
film school and everyone's about
going out there making their mark and
when you're younger it's definitely more
about competition and wanting to prove
yourself and then
maybe life
has different knocks and different
things happen and it becomes more about
meaning
and so maybe that's also something
that's
you know after
30 years
it's more about what does this project
mean to me and and am i doing what i
want to be doing
i think that's a big part of it um
i think that
if we can grow from everything we do you
know i think that's the key is growth
and and trying to build something
special so the next one is better and
bigger it doesn't mean it's going to be
financially bigger or financially better
but the experience and i think when you
have
an atmosphere on a set
that people feel a part of regardless of
the guys coming in once a week to empty
the toilets or the start of the show if
people feel a part of something i think
it really shows on screen you know we
talk about that a lot in the book is
temperament respect on a set and how it
ultimately is going to affect your
actors you know they are such sensitive
beings their their antennas are way out
they're picking up on every nuance of
mood
the director and dp are pissed off at
each other an ad is upset or snippy they
they they pick up on that
and
you know i just i think what i was
trying to say earlier
is that
i think
i think everybody is truly in our
industry it's every man for themselves
but i think it it shows too much i think
people need to remember that it it takes
a village it takes
it takes a unit
you know we don't
we don't
storm countries or going to war
thinking about one or two people we go
in as a unit you know
and
i just would like to see more of that
in our industry
you